Quân mừng được gặp bắt con cộng đồng trận chuyến tham chính thức liên bằng nha
Thủ tướng bây tỏ dù đã đến nha nhiều lần
Những mỗi gì được gặp và cho chuyện với bắt con
Điều rất súc động trước tình dân tộc giã đồng bảo
Cuộc đồng tạnh nha
Một cộng đồng đoàn kết, chữ thương chủ khó, tháng công và có tấm lòng như thành
Với quay hình đánh hức
Thủ bướng phạm mi chính cho biết
Sợi chỉ đóo chuyên xuất là tình cảm
Người ngán nói đến người Việt Nam
Là một sự ấm cũng một sự gần của ý và người lại
Người Việt Nam nói đến người nha
Là sự ấm áp, gần vui
Này là tình cảm rất tự nhiên của nước tự lịch sử khó khăn dân lào của đến nước Việt Nam
Chúng ta chân trọng tình cảm của những dân nha
Nhà nước nha, dân tộc nha, lối với đến nước Việt Nam
Chúng ta phải làm sao cho sứng đáng với tình cảm này
Thì làm ở nha, hay làm việc ở Việt Nam
Hãy ở lĩnh vực nào thì cũng ý đến tình cảm của hai nước
Bích chân trọng của mình
Và tiếp tục phát viên dưỡng ngày càng tốt hơn
Chân trọng khi nhận và đánh ra cao sự nỗ lực
Bản lĩnh chỉ tuổi a của bà con thời gian vừa qua
Vừa qua nhiều biến động thứ thách
Bà con vẫn dưới bững tình thần kinh cường
Bể tiếp tục vừa lên
Khội nhật tốt và khẳng định bị thể ở sự tại
Thủ đướng cho biết trong chuyến thâm là này
Sẽ hồi kiến hồi đàm với tất cả các lãnh đạo các cơ cao của nha
Để đánh ra khi quà hợp tác thời gian qua
Đồng thời sách định phương viễn thời gian tới
Trong đòi yêu tiên chào đổi và đến gỷ chính quyền các cơ quan chức năng của nha
Tết tục tạo điều kiện thật lợi
Để bà con tăng ngày càng có điều vị pháp li vững chắc
Ông định cuộc sống, ít tâm kinh doanh làm việc hào tập
Thủ đướng mong muốn cộng đồng người Việt Nam tại nha
Ngay càng đơn kết
Ông định có vị thế bững chắc trong giả hội sở tại
Trời thành câu lối gắn kết chặt chẽ cho quan hệ hành nước
Mong cộng đồng tiếp tục chắc hành tốt pháp lợt nước sở tại
Hào tập làm việc hành xây
Chánh thủ hào hỏi kiến thức kiến năng công nghệ
Kinh nghiệm khoảng lý của nước bạn
Tăng kưởng kết nối túc đầy đầu tư
Có nhiều hả đồng tiếp tực hơn nữa về tục quốc
Tí tục diên giữ phát y bản sắc quan hóa
Môn người Việt trong bởi sống
Có phần khoảng bá lành toàn ra chỉ có đẹp của dịch tục tà ra thế giới
Lãnh kết bình chặt các thế hệ người còn sắc sử với cộng môn
Thủ đướng đề nghị đại sự quan Việt Nam tại nha
Lãnh tốt hơn nữa cộng tác mạo hộ công dân
Chăm lo cho kiểu bảo tà ở sắc sử
Tại sự quan phải là mạnh nhà chung đềm được vững chắc
Nơi người gắn đềm biên ký vọc
Và tình cảm của tòan thế cộng đồng bà có tà tại liên bà ngàn
Đồng thời đen nghiệm nghiêm kí uống thành lập hội liên nhập của nữ tại liên bà ngàn
Thủ đướng mong bà con, giữa bất cứ đâu
Lồn đoàn kết một lòng, sắc cạnh cùng nhau
Nguyễn dưỡng tình rất tộc giữa đồng bà ở trong tàm thức
Bộ đáp tình yêu tổ quốc trong trái tim
Một lòng hướng về quen thường xử dờ, trên đi ngọt nữa
Thát bọng công viễn xe dựng nước nhà nghe càng sâu đề hơn